JUST TWO DAYS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
RESPONDED BY SENDING HUNDREDS OF
TROOPS.
SOME OUTLETS SLAMMING THE
PRESIDENT IS EVEN TRYING TO
LABEL THE INCIDENT AS TRUMP'S
BENGHAZI.
HERE'S A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
COVERAGE.
>> YOU'VE GOT THEM STOKING
ANTI-AMERICANISM, GIVING AN
ADVANTAGE TO IRAN.
SPEAK OF THIS GOES BACK TO A
RELEASE STRATEGIC DECISION THAT
THE PRESIDENT MADE.
>> THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT
HELPFUL.
>> THESE ARE TOUGH TIMES AND ONE
WORRIES WHETHER THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS THE SORT OF
HORSE POWER AND BRAINPOWER TO
DEAL WITH THEM.
>> Dana: AND MSNBC PILING ON,
CALLING THE EMBASSY ATTACKED
TRUMP'S BENGHAZI.
OTHER OUTLETS UNDER FIRE FOR
LABELING THE IRANIAN BACKED
MILITANTS AS JUST PROTESTERS.
TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS ALSO
FACING SIMILAR CRITICISM FOR
DESCRIBING THE ATTACKERS AS
MOURNERS.
A FORMER BENGHAZI TEAM MEMBER IS
BLASTING THE BENGHAZI
COMPARISON.
>> IT'S NOT REALLY SIMILAR AT
ALL.
IT'S NOT ANOTHER BENGHAZI.
IT'S NOT EVEN TRUMP'S BENGHAZI
APPEARED TO ME, IT IS NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO BENGHAZI.
ALL PERSONNEL WERE EVACUATED.
THERE WAS NO INVESTOR THEY ARE
TO BE KILLED LIKE THEY LEFT THE
INVESTOR IN BENGHAZI.
>> Dana: LAWRENCE, THERE
WOULDN'T BE COMPARISONS TO
BENGHAZI IF THERE WASN'T A
BENGHAZI.
AND IT REALLY IS NOT COMPARABLE.
>> Lawrence: AT ALL.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
RIOT, HE WAS ALSO THERE, AND
COORDINATED ATTACK AND THE
RESPONSE WAS ALSO DIFFERENT.
THERE WERE NO LIVES LOST.
THE FACT IS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IMMEDIATELY AND THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT, THE SECRETARY OF
STATE ALL STEPPED IN AND MADE
SURE THERE WERE PEOPLE THERE,
THE MARINES WERE ALREADY THERE,
PEOPLE WERE BEING SHIFTED AND
NOBODY DIED.
I JUST THINK THIS SHOWS YOU HOW
FAR THE MEDIA IS WILLING TO GO
TO GIVE COVER TO DEMOCRATS.
AND YOU'D THINK WHEN IT COMES TO
NATIONAL SECURITY, FOREIGN
POLICY, ALTHOUGH WE MAY HAVE
SOME DIFFERENCES, WHEN IT COMES
TO ATTACK, WE SHOULD BE UNIFIED.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW PROBABLY
MORE ABOUT THIS ATTACK THAN
ANYBODY HERE SO WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THE ATTEMPTS TO
COMPARE THIS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED
IN BENGHAZI WAS A VIDEOMAKER GOT
ARRESTED AND BASICALLY THEY DID
A WALK OF HIM SAYING THE VIDEO
SPARKED THE ATTACK WHEN WE KNOW
THAT WASN'T TRUE.
>> Marie: THEY ARE VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS.
THE COMPOUND IN BAGHDAD IS VERY
WELL PROTECTED.
A BETTER COMPARISON TO BENGHAZI
WAS AN ATTACK EARLIER IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WHEN FOUR
MEMBERS OF THE ADMINISTRATION
WERE KILLED IN A VERY BOTCHED
OPERATION.
I DON'T THINK THE COMPARISON IS
FAIR HERE.
SOME PEOPLE IN THE CLIPS WEREN'T
TALKING ABOUT BENGHAZI, THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP STRATEGY IS
VIS-A-VIS IRAN AND WHETHER HE
HAS ONE, FRANKLY.
MY CONCERNS ARE NOT ABOUT THE
BENGHAZI, IT'S ABOUT MUCH OF
WHAT TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
DONE IN IRAN, THE IG FEELS LIKE
THEY SHOULD ENCOURAGE THEIR
MILITIAS IN IRAQ AND SYRIA TO DO
THIS AND WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO RESPOND.
THE ISRAELIS HAVE TAKEN A LOT OF
KINETIC ACTION AGAINST SHIITE
MILITIAS BACKED BY IRAN BUT THEY
DO IT MUCH MORE QUIETLY BECAUSE
THEY ARE TRYING TO SEND A
MESSAGE BUT NOT PROVOKE SOME OF
THE OUTRAGE WE'VE SEEN ON THE
GROUND WHICH CAN PUT SOME OF OUR
PEOPLE IN HARM'S WAY'S.
THE RESULT OF THAT IS WE DON'T
OF PEOPLE ON THE GROUND DOING
AMERICAN DIPLOMACY.
>> Dana: THEY ARE THERE TO
HELP PROTECT THEM BUT ONE REASON
IRAN HAS BEEN ABLE TO TRAIN UP
ALL THESE OTHER MILITIAS IS
BECAUSE THEY GOT HIM
BECAUSE THEY GOT AIM
BECAUSE THEY GOT A LOT OF MONEY
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tom: WHAT DIFFERENCE AT
THIS POINT DOESN'T MAKE?
>> Dana: CALLBACK, THAT IS A
CALL BACK RIGHT THERE.
>> Tom: I WANT TO SHAME THE
MEDIA ON THIS BECAUSE THE
HEADLINES FROM IT LOOKS LIKE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THEY HAVE
TO DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN --
THERE ARE PROTESTS IN IRAQ SIX
OCTOBER.
THIS IS WHAT YOU'VE SEEN ON
TWITTER, I AM ONE OF THE REAL
PROTESTERS, I'VE BEEN PROTESTING
THIS GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THEY ARE
VERY ANGRY IN IRAQ, THEY WANT
REFORMS.
THEY CAME IN AND PIGGYBACKED ON
THOSE PROTESTS AND THE MEETING
NEEDS TO DIFFERENTIATE AND THEY
ARE NOT DOING THEIR JOB.
>> Dana: THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS DONE THAT BUT WE HAVE SOME
SOUNDS HERE FROM PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT TRUMP -- I'M LIKE,
EMILY?
I LOOKED UP AND I WAS LIKE, I'M
GOING TO REMEMBER YOUR NAME.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT DAY OF
THE WEEK IT IS, ACTUALLY.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING DURING THE
HOLIDAYS AND IF YOU'RE LIKE ME
YOU ARE LIKE, IS IT FRIDAY?
AS OF MONDAY?
I HAVE NO IDEA.
TAKE A LOOK AT PRESIDENT TRUMP,
WHO OBVIOUSLY KNOWS WHAT DAY IT
IS.
>> WE HAD SOME GREAT WARRIORS
COME IN, DO A FANTASTIC JOB.
THEY WERE THERE INSTANTANEOUSLY.
AS SOON AS WE HEARD, I USED THE
WORD IMMEDIATELY.
THEY CAME IN IMMEDIATELY.
GREAT SHAPE.
AS YOU KNOW, THIS WILL NOT BE A
BENGHAZI.
BENGHAZI NEVER SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED.
THIS WILL NEVER, EVER BE A
BENGHAZI.
>> Emily: IT IS NOT COMPARABLE
ON ANY LEVEL.
WE HAVE MADE EFFORTS NOT TO BACK
IRANIAN MILITIAS AS WE HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING ISIS THIS WHOLE TIME,
AND THE CONTINUED AGGRESSION
WILL NOT BE TOLERATED.
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT THERE IS A
BIT OF NEBULOUS NOTES AND
STRATEGY IN THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE
HAVE TAKEN THAT HARD LINE STANCE
WITH A VERY ARTICULABLE POSITION
THAT WILL SERVE US WELL IN THE
LONG TERM.
I THINK THE IRAQI GOVERNMENT,
OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE IN A
DIFFICULT POSITION BUT
REGARDLESS, THEY NEED TO TAKE A
STANCE, THEY NEED TO PROTECT OUR
EMBASSY, AND TO YOUR POINT NOT